What would a conversation look like with zero
questions? This is a bit of an odd question
that crossed my desk. But I have a really fun
answer that has transformed the way that I
dive in and engage in conversation with people
both in personal life and also with my wife
and also in work relationships in a work context.
And it's really interesting. Not that I recommend
diving into a conversation and asking no
questions at all. In fact, me and Will wrote
a book about How To Ask Questions in order
to create conversations that really matter.
And yet, if you completely remove questions
from your conversational vocabulary,
in this video, I'm going to share 4 levels of
listening that create the opportunity to have
a really fantastic conversation even though you
haven't asked necessarily. If you stick around
the video, I'm also going to share 15 phrases
that are really, really phenomenal phrases
that create better conversation, better listening.
These are phrases that can be perfectly fitted to
whatever context and content of the conversation
that you're in. And they're really, really useful
as reflective listening phrases. So, in a world
where you couldn't ask any questions or for some
reason you just were aware of how many questions
you were asking, it started to feel a bit like
an interrogation. These 15 phrases are really,
really useful to pull out of your back pocket
to ensure that somebody feels heard and
the conversation continues forward with
a little bit of momentum. I'm Chad. Happy to be
in cyberspace with you today. Let's get into it.
When I'm watching a video, I love to know
kind of the path of where we're going
before we get strung along too much. So, the 4
levels of listening are verbatim, translation,
unstated feelings, and connecting the dots. Let's
take each one of those and expand them a little
bit. At the end of this video, you will 100% be
a better listener. If for some reason, you feel
cheated by this video and you don't feel like a
better listener and a better conversationalist,
at the end of this video, you can write me an
angry email. Find my email somewhere and me and
will will send you a free copy of Ask Powerful
Questions Create Conversations That Matter.
Alright. You've got to prove to us though
that you learn nothing in this video.
So, verbatim reflection. So, first of all, all 4
of these levels of listening are really levels of
reflective listening. And reflective listening
is the idea that if I were to hold up a mirror
to your words or whatever you're saying to me,
"I'm just going to hold up and reflect them
back to you." Now, there's lots of ways that
you can reflect. If you've ever been into a
fun house at a circus or something, there's
the mirror that's kind of curved that makes
you look really long, there's one that makes
you look really wide. And then there's just a
normal mirror. Point is you can reflect in lots of
different ways. First way is verbatim reflection.
So, the first way is verbatim reflection. Do you
see what I just did there? Just literally repeated
exactly what I just said verbatim. Word for word.
And that is the idea of verbatim reflection. Now,
this sounds ridiculous and when I first
learned it, it felt ridiculous to do. But I
was shocked. I still am shocked that when I
verbatim reflect what I heard somebody else say
how frequently, they either say, "Oh, that's
exactly what I mean." Or they're like, "No,
no, no, no, no." This is what I meant and then
they actually clarify. It's phenomenal. Like,
literally just feeding somebody's words back.
And I think it's partially because we're in our
own heads. And as we're speaking, we don't hear
exactly what we sound like when we're speaking
necessarily. And so, that verbatim reflection
is a really easy way to reflect back. Keep a
conversation going forward. Now, I will say
verbatim reflection is probably most likely to
end a conversation if the person's like, "Yeah,
that's exactly what I got." And so, if your
goal is to have a conversation with by asking no
questions, that might be a tough one. Second one
is translation. So, that is where I take most of
your words edit them a little bit and then repeat
them back. Right? I might take your language and
put it into my language. So, there are 2 types of
translation. You can do a simple translation and
a far out translation. Simple translation. Just
making some slight tweaks so that it doesn't sound
like I just parroted back exactly what you said.
Far out translation is where I'm using my own
words as the listener and expanding on meaning.
So, if you tell me... If I ask you, "How was your
day?" And you tell me, "It was really good. I had
a big win at work. And family life is good",
I could say simple translation. Wow, it sounds
like you had a really good day at work and things
are going really smoothly with your family, right?
Just a simple translation. Nothing too crazy. Now,
if you said that same thing a far out translation,
might look like, "Wow, it sounds like your life as
a whole is going really, really well." Do you see
how that was my own words... And I even expanded
on the meaning of what you just said in that
moment. Now, the power of a far out translation is
when you expand that meaning, you often invite a
really thoughtful response from the other person.
Either clarifying or expanding on what you've just
said. Because you've taken some liberties and gone
extended the conversation, extended what they said
a little bit further than what they actually said.
Harder to do but extremely powerful if done well.
The third level of reflective listening is
reflecting back unstated feelings. And this is a
really useful one that is extremely underutilized.
And what I mean by that is when we speak,
words come out of our mouth. And most of the time,
depending on who it is, most of the time they're
not necessarily filled with emotional words.
They're not... You know, people don't necessarily
say, "I'm really sad right now or I'm really angry
right now." Sometimes we do. But more often than
not, we're describing something that's really
making us really frustrated. But we don't say,
"I'm angry." Just we see that frustration. And
so, reflecting back unstated feelings would be
something along the lines of just looking back at
them and observing, "Hey, I can see that you're
really frustrated right now". In fact, my wife and
I are reading this parenting book together. And I
love the... There was a comic in it that showed a
kid who bumped his head and was crying screaming
really reacting. And the parent was just... There
was 2 types of parents. One was... And the most
common thing that we do with people's feelings is
deny and dismiss them. You see, somebody's feeling
really sad. You're like, "No, no. It's okay. It'll
be good. Like this is only temporary." Blah, blah,
blah. Right? So, you kind of dismiss and deny.
But the idea here was to unpack a little bit
further to talk with the kid, to get them
to share and unpack why it is that they're
sad and to acknowledge to get them to realize that
sometimes they're not sad. Because especially when
a kid is really, really sad, that is all they can
think about, right? They're so absorbed in that
world. Whereas if you're able to pull out and you
have some unstated feelings reflected back at you,
it gives you some more awareness and some more
choice over your emotions which is an extremely
powerful gift to give to somebody. And then the
fourth level of reflective listening is really,
really cool, connecting the dots. This is where
you get to take people and connect them to ideas
and connect people to people and ideas to ideas in
the way that you actually listen and feedback. And
so, I used to work for an organization called
World And Conversation and my job was to sit
down with a group of strangers and talk about
really soft fluffy topics like race, relations,
long-term conflict, politics, religion, etc with
no agenda other than to understand the other.
And one of the neatest things that would happen
in those conversations maybe about 60 minutes
into the conversation is there would be so much
conversational data, so much story, so much
experience out on the table that people were
sharing that there were just so many dots that
could be connected in that conversation. In fact,
I was in one conversation a dialogue with a kid
who was black grew up going to a 98% black school
in new york city and a kid who grew up in rural
North Carolina where I may not have seen somebody
who was black especially at school. And now,
they're sitting in the same room in a conversation
with being facilitated by me about race relations.
And at the end of the conversation, they looked at
each other and said, "Dude, you are just like me."
It was such a powerful moment because and what
sparked that was they actually connected the
dots themselves. I can't take any credit
for that aha or that bridge building.
And what essentially brought that up was at one
point, somebody was sharing that their parents
told them when they went out of the house to watch
out for white people and to be mindful of the way
you were acting around white people. And somebody
else's parents said, when you walk into the house,
be mindful of how you interact around or with
people who are black. In that conversation,
they saw and they actually they saw these dots
being connected. They actually looked at each
other and said, "Dude, you're just like
me." And that's the power of really great
connecting the dot type of listening, is as the
facilitator or as a leader or as an educator,
to be able to connect what somebody's talking
about now with what they did talk about the in
the past or what somebody else talked about in the
past or to connect 2 people in the present. Just
having the language of thinking about listening
to connect the dots will make you a really,
really fun conversationalist to be around. So, now
that you've got 4 levels of reflective listening.
It's helpful to have phrases that mix up the way
that reflective listening sounds. Because you
don't want to sound like Dr. Phil that just says,
"I hear you saying. I hear you saying. I hear you
saying." Right? Repeat back. Because when you're
reflective listening too much you can start to
sound like a therapist or a counselor which likely
if you're watching this video is not your goal
or your aim. And so, here are a bunch of different
phrases from page 138 in Ask Powerful Questions
that you can use to start reflective listening
statements. Now, my editors are going to just
fill up the screen with them so that you can pause
and screenshot them if you want. My invitation
before I read them off and share them with you,
my invitation is for you to pick out 2 or 3
that are not your normal vocabulary of listening
and add them to your back pocket. Because
when you're able to mix it up, even just between
2 or 3, you don't need 15 phrases necessarily.
But pick 2 or 3 that feel like you that you'd feel
comfortable using in conversation and just have
them in your back pocket. It's a really great
way to keep a conversation meaningfully going
without questions. And also to make somebody
feel heard right? In the same way that a mirror
makes somebody feel seen, reflective
listening makes somebody feel heard.
So, you might be able to say,
"So, you are wondering...
You believe... So, you're thinking about...
I hear you saying. So, what you are saying
is... You seem... I'm getting... You think... It
is important to you... It feels like you are...
What I'm understanding is... It sounds
to me like... You sound as if you are...
Sounds like from your perspective...
It seems as though..." Okay,
I don't actually know if that was 15 or not but
here's a handful of phrases. If you want more,
you can download a free excerpt of this online. If
you enjoyed this video, you also love these ones.
It was awesome hanging out in cyberspace with
you. I'm Chad Littlefield. Have an awesome day.